Narrator: Broadway shows
don't last forever.
But some of the costumes used
on stage can get a second act,
thanks to a not-for-profit organization
called the TDF Costume Collection.
Cabral: We have a dress from
"Wicked," worn by Elphaba,
as well as one of the
"Mamma Mia!" jumpsuits.
Narrator: That's Stephen
Cabral, the director
of the collection, which is
based in Astoria, Queens.
TDF accepts donations from
various theatrical performances
at the end of their run and rents them
back out to other performances for reuse.
Cabral: We do approximately
1,000 productions a year,
renting over 10,000 costumes,
both here in New York City
as well as nationwide.
Narrator: They have over 80,000 items
in their collection,
including shoes, shirts,
dresses, hats, gloves, and
various other accessories.
Cabral: A lot of times
when a Broadway show
will eventually close,
the costumes are usually
retained for the tour or backup.
But every once in a while,
a Broadway show will say,
"Okay, we're done with these
clothes; you can have them."
Narrator: TDF started
back in the early '70s,
when the Metropolitan Opera
moved to Lincoln Center
and donated costumes from 22 shows.
TDF has since expanded,
offering all sorts of items
donated from a variety of
performances and individuals.
Cabral: Recently, we
received a rather large
and very exciting donation.
Hollywood, Broadway fashion
designer, Bob Mackie.
Narrator: Some notable pieces
Mackie donated were a dress
worn by Julia Louis Dreyfuss
at the 1997 Emmy awards
and an entire production
of "The Best Little
Whorehouse Goes Public."
Cabral: When the original
production of "Rent"
finally closed,
after running for many, many years,
we were very fortunate to receive
all of the original
costumes from the original
off-Broadway production,
before it moved to Broadway.
We received many donations over the years
from "Mamma Mia!" when
"Mamma Mia!" was on Broadway.
We have a dress worn by Jane Krakowski
from a recent production
of "She Loves Me,"
some costumes worn by Patti Lupone
in the revival of "Gypsy."
Narrator: While many of
the items are iconic,
you won't necessarily find something worn
by big celebrities like
Cher or Barbara Streisand.
Cabral: Many celebrities
actually wanna hold on
to their costumes,
either to potentially open
a museum or more likely
later on in life have some
sort of celebrity auction.
Narrator: Many amateur stage
performances rent from TDF,
but so do some TV shows and movies.
Cabral: "Saturday Night
Live," when they're filming,
depending on their season and their needs,
is in here sometimes every week.
Narrator: TDF costumes can be seen
in this skit with Betty White.
"Now all we need is a
dress and some proper shoes
and a little womanly allure."
Narrator: And this skit with
Justin Timberlake as Mozart.
Both "Birdman" and "12 Years a Slave"
featured costumes in the film
that were rented here from
the TDF Costume Collection.
Cabral: The only type of
rental that we really don't do
is Halloween.
Our costumes are really
not Halloween-worthy.
We also try to avoid doing rentals
where there is any food
or beverage involved.
Narrator: Anyone can go in
and explore the collection.
But if you wanna try anything on,
you have to fill out some paperwork first.
They have mannequins you
can use to check sizes
and dressing rooms you
can book in advance.
"Here I go!"
Narrator: Cost is based on a whole look,
not per individual item.
Cabral: The other part
of our pricing exists
with number of weeks
of performances and how
large your theater is.
Narrator: You also have to pay
to have the costumes dry
cleaned before returning them.
Stephen says they have a
green strategy in place
to make sure all the items
get as much use as possible.
Once an item gets too ragged,
it's moved to a special area,
where these types of items are in demand.
Cabral: We have a distressed section.
So for productions like
"Les Mis" or "Urinetown,"
these are costumes that
need to not look so great.
Narrator: And two or three times a year,
they open up the warehouse
for a special bag sale.
Cabral: You pay for that bag, you go in,
and whatever you can shove into that bag
and take out the door is yours.
Narrator: So no matter what
condition a costume is in,
there's always a chance
at an encore performance.
Cabral: We sometimes will put costumes
on people and there's nothing.
Nothing changes, they're
just kind of like, "Eh."
Then you put costumes on people
and it brings out a whole
other personality or two.
And it's kind of fun.
"Lovely to meet you."